Traductor: Denise RQ
Revisor: Sebastian Betti
En 1898, Marie y Pierre Curie
descubrieron el radio.
Afirmando que tiene
propiedades curativas,
añadieron radio a la pasta de dientes,
a los medicamentos, al agua y la comida.
Debido a su color verde
brillante y luminoso,
también se usó en productos
de belleza y joyas.
Hasta mediados del siglo XX
no nos dimos cuenta
de que los efectos nocivos
del elemento radiactivo radio
superaban sus atractivos visuales.
Desafortunadamente, el radio
no es el único elemento químico
que parecía inofensivo o útil
en el pasado como pigmento
pero resultó ser letal.
Esta lamentable distinción incluye
un trío de colores y pigmentos
que hace mucho que usamos
para embellecernos y decorar
las cosas que hacemos:
se trata del blanco, el verde
y el naranja.
Nuestra historia comienza con el blanco.
Ya en el siglo IV antes de Cristo,
los antiguos griegos trataron
de obtener del plomo
un brillante pigmento blanco
que hoy conocemos.
¿El problema?
En los seres humanos, el plomo
se absorbe directamente en el cuerpo
e invade la sangre, los tejidos
blandos y los tejidos mineralizados.
Una vez que llega al sistema nervioso,
el plomo imita y altera
las funciones normales del calcio,
causando daños como problemas de
aprendizaje o presión arterial alta.
Sin embargo, la práctica
de usar este pigmento tóxico
continuó a lo largo
del tiempo y de las culturas.
El plomo blanco fue
la única opción práctica
para el aceite blanco o pintura
témpera hasta el siglo XIX.
Para hacer su pintura, los artistas molían
un bloque de plomo en polvo,
quedando expuestos a partículas
de polvo altamente tóxicas.
El uso libre del pigmento resultó en
lo que se conoce como cólico del pintor,
o lo que ahora llamaríamos
envenenamiento por plomo.
Los artistas que trabajaron con el plomo
se quejaron de parálisis, melancolía, tos,
aumento de retina e incluso ceguera.
Pero la densidad del plomo blanco,
su opacidad y el tono caliente
fueron irresistibles para artistas como
Vermeer y más tarde, los impresionistas.
Su resplandor no podía ser igualado
y el pigmento continuó
usándose ampliamente
hasta que fue prohibido
en los años 70.
Por malo que suena todo esto,
los efectos nocivos del plomo
no son nada en comparación
con otro pigmento
aún más extendido, el verde.
Dos colores verdes sintéticos llamados
el verde de Scheele y el verde de París
se introdujeron por primera
vez en el siglo XVIII.
Eran mucho más vibrantes y llamativos
que los verdes relativamente aburridos
hechos de pigmentos naturales,
así que se convirtieron rápidamente
en dos opciones populares para la pintura
así como tinte para los textiles,
el papel pintado, el jabón,
decoración para postres,
juguetes, dulces y ropa.
Estos pigmentos verdes se hacían
a base de un compuesto llamado
acetoarsenito de cobre.
En humanos, la exposición
al arsénico puede dañar
la manera en la que las células
se comunican y funcionan.
Y altos niveles de arsénico
se han vinculado directamente
al cáncer y las enfermedades cardíacas.
Como resultado, los que trabajaban
en fábricas el siglo XVIII
sufrían a menudo de envenenamiento
y las mujeres que llevaban vestidos verdes
aparentemente se desmayaban
debido al contacto
del arsénico con su piel.
Se rumoreaba que los insectos caseros
no vivían en cuartos de color verde,
e incluso se ha especulado
que Napoleón murió
por envenenamiento lento con arsénico
por dormir en su dormitorio decorado
con papel pintado de color verde.
La gran toxicidad de estos verdes
se mantuvo en secreto
hasta que la receta de arsénico
se hizo pública en 1822.
Y un siglo más tarde,
se usaba como insecticida.
El verde sintético fue probablemente
el color más peligroso de uso común
pero al menos no compartía la propiedad
de radioactividad del radio.
No obstante otro color, el naranja,
sí que era también radioactivo.
Antes de la Segunda Guerra
Mundial era normal
para los fabricantes
de vajillas de cerámica
usar el óxido de uranio
para dar color a los esmaltes.
El compuesto obtenido al combinar
brillantes rojos y naranjas,
constituyan atributos atractivos
si no fuera por la radiación que emitían.
Por supuesto, no estuvimos conscientes
de la radiación hasta finales de 1800,
y mucho menos de los riesgos asociados
al cáncer que descubrimos mucho más tarde.
Durante la Segunda Guerra Mundial,
el gobierno de EE.UU.
confiscó todo el uranio
para usarlo en el desarrollo de bombas.
Sin embargo, la comisión de energía
atómica relajó estas restricciones en 1959
y el uranio empobrecido fue devuelto
a la cerámica y la fabricación
de suelos de vidrio.
Los platos color naranja hechos
durante la próxima década
pueden aún tener ciertas
cualidades peligrosas
a la superficie hasta el día de hoy.
Más notablemente,
los objetos para las fiestas
pueden aún dar positivo en radiactividad.
Y mientras los niveles son
lo suficientemente bajos
para no representar oficialmente
un riesgo para la salud
si están en una estantería,
el Instituto Nacional
de Estadística de EE.UU.
advierte no comer alimentos
de estos objetos.
Aunque todavía surgen ocasionalmente
con los colorantes
alimentarios sintéticos,
los datos científicos
nos ha ayudado a eliminar
los colores peligrosos de nuestras vidas.